الى العمليه العسكريه التركيه التي اعلنت
عنها وزاره الدفاع التركيه حيث نفذت
مقاتلتها غارات في ساعه متاخرا من مسائي
امس السبت على معاقل ما وصفتها بالتنظيمات
الارهابيه الشماليه سوريا والعراق في
اشاره الى حزب العمال الكردستاني وحلفاء
المشاهد الاولى للغارات وقالت في
تغريد ان العمليه تهدف للقصاص لما وصفته
بالهجوم الغادر في اشاره الى انفجار الذي
وقع الاسبوع الماضي في اسطنبول وادى الى
سقوطه قتلى وجرحه
طالما واقعه عسكريه لما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه في تل رفعت وعند دقنه بريف
حلب وشمال عين عيسى في الرقه ومناطق في
الحسكه وعين العرب كوباني على الحدود
السوريه
الديمقراطيه والتي تشكل وحدات حمايه الشعب
الكرديه عمودها الفقري ان طائرات تركيه
قصفت قريتين ماهونتين بالنازحين السوريا
وزير دفاع تركيا خلصي اكار قال ان الضربات
الجويه التي نفذتها القوات التركيه على
مواقع في منطقه عين العرب شمال الشرقيه
سوريا وشمال العراق نجحت في تدمير مواقع
ومقر لحزب العمال للكردستاني ووحدات حمايه
الشعب الكرديه الذين وصفهما بالمنظمتين
الارهابيتين
التي تعود الارهابيين وتعقبنا ذلك عن كذب
وتم تدميره بكل دقه مقرا تابعا للمنظمه
الارهابيه واستهداف الارهابيين والمواقع
التي تخصها فقط ومخلب القوات المسلحه
التركيه استهدف الارهابيين مره اخرى
ولدينا القدره والاصرار على انقاذ بلدنا
وشعبنا من بلاء الارهاب المصلى عليهم منذ
40 عاما ولم يترك ابدا ساقرا شهدائنا
ومواطنين
الينا من انقر مراسله الجزيره فرح الزمان
شوقي فرح انطلاقا من كلام خلوصي اكار هل
قدمت السلطات التركيه سقف زمن لهذه
العمليه وهل من معطيات جديده بخصوص
تطوراتها كذلك
نعم وسيله بحسب المواقع الرسميه التركيه
هذه العمليه بدات في تمام الساعه 11:00 من
مساء يوم امس اعلنت عنها وزاره الدفاع
التركيه في الواحده بعد منتصف الليل عبر
تغريده على تويتر قالت فيها بانه انا اوان
الحساب في اشاره منها الى ان هذه العمليه
تاتي ردا على التفجير الذي وقع في شارع
على استقلال في اسطنبول قبل اسبوع بالضبط
تجددت ضربات الجويه تحديدا على مواقع من
عين العرب كوباني شمال
شرق سوريا وقال التلفزيون الرسمي التركي
بان هذه الضربات الاخيره نفذتها مسيرات
تركيه بكل الاحوال وزير الدفاع
ظهر كذلك في شريط مصور من مقر للقوات
الجويه التركيه بعد ان تلقى حاطه من
قائدها حول هذه العمليه واداره بنفسه هذه
العمليه وجاءت تصريحاته لتؤكد بانه تدمير
مواقع تابعه للارهابيين على حد وصفه في
اشاره لحزب العمال الكردستاني ووحدات
حمايه الشعب الكرديه في كل من شمالي سوريا
والعراق وقال ان هذه العمليه يطلق عليها
اسم المخلب السيف ويقول بانها ستستمر
بمعنى انها ستكون عباره عن عمليه على
مراحل وهذه المرحله هي المرحله الاولى
منها وحسب يشير هنا الى نقطه بالغه
الاهميه ويقول ان تركيا اجرى الدراساتها
الدقيقه قبل ان تنفذ هذه الضربات بمعنى
يحاول ان يزيح على الانتقادات عن اهل
تركيا بالقول بانه لم يتم استهداف اي
مدنيين او بنا تحتيه مدنيه على حد تعبيره
هذا الكلام ايضا جاء في تغريد سابقه
لوزاره الدفاع التركيه التي تؤكد بان هذه
العمليه لا تخالف القوانين بمعنى انها
تنفذ وفقا للبند الواحد والخمسين من قانون
الامم المتحده الذي يسمح لتركيا بالدفاع
عن نفسها وهذا بحسب السلطات التركيه
المواقع الصحفيه ايضا تتحدث عن مشاركه
مقاتلات من طراز اف سته عشر في هذه
العمليه على الشمالي سوريا والعراق الى
جانب المسيرات التركيه لم تعلن السلطات
بعد عن عدد من تم قتلهم او تم تحديدهم
بحسب المصطلح الذي تفضل وزاره الدفاع
التركيه استخدامهم دائما اتوقع ان يتم ذلك
همم خلال همم وقت همم لاحق من اليوم الى
جانب ذلك تتوالى المواقف والتصريحات
الرسميه التركيه والتي تؤكد بان هذه
العمليات ستستمر
مرحله اولى نقطه اخيره مساله استهداف عين
العرب لها دلاله اذ قالت تحقيقات التركيه
بان منفذ هجوم شارع الاستقلال تلقى
التدريباتها واوامرها من انا عين العرب
ولذلك تركز تركيا تحديدا جغرافيه على هذه
القيمه